[Music]
in comeback news a more like comeback Oh
me get submitted by Baxter backstabbers
bastard remember no Evan Baxter no very
good what is it
what reference our ladies o busan
amazing memory that's I didn't know that
really yeah liar liar liar
yeah Wow good job a naked woman chased a
man through traffic after he fled their
hotel room Oh what does she do queef and
then he ran away and then she's like you
better make this [ __ ] [ __ ] I you
better make my [ __ ] calm yeah you got
it
they're all in the middle [ __ ] she's
like he's like you I don't like that and
then he starts running yeah he's running
away and gets in his car I think you
come on come on she's about she's about
to touch the car
whoa whoa better not leave before making
me famous
[Music]
it should be a crime I don't even think
he went in the car think he just ran on
the freeway
Oh [ __ ] on the 4 or 5 up
hey Frogger he okay no what do you mean
maybe don't show the facts over there
hmm I guess them all hey Jimmy maybe
which me maybe no all right so this
woman she was arrested after she was
seen in public fully nude chasing after
this man and so what this van said is
that she so they knew each other from
high school yes and then they got a room
together at super 8 hmm how romantic
unrequited love serious of motels yeah
yeah he's 47 by the way super 8 is 2 up
on the motel 6 yeah how come it's a
number two stars above it it's two above
yeah so then he was saying that she was
acting crazy and saying that they were
gonna have kids and start a life
together normal [ __ ] it is a good as
crazy for a hookup though because it's
like oh let's just get a motel [ __ ]
right and then afterwards are like let's
get married but not really because
they've known each other since high
school
yeah it's 4708 unrequited love you said
Oh [ __ ] during that age yeah so my
dad it's odd it's definitely odd but
it's not as crazy like this - my dad was
dating right now
and like the first two dates went good
you'd marry her on the third one oh yeah
what yeah when they're like that age
they don't give a [ __ ] like okay I can
get a Wow
it's cuz I'm imagining her to be like
since we just did it now when are you
gonna propose because I'm ready to get
married and have my life with you right
because I don't got a lot of [ __ ] you
know that's like since you already stuck
it in now you know I'm yours forever no
you can't leave now that's why I did the
stone that's high school [ __ ] yeah
any of my younger years I would have
been so horny but I'm a little scary but
you gave me good [ __ ] so I got
ah but I gotta keep going service
carries no one that was chasing after oh
[ __ ] that's the picture of the guy words
carry no that's a mr. clean Edwards
carrier she looks like Billy Idol and
[ __ ] she does she reminded me of that
soup that model woman that was with the
guy with the clocks oh my god forgetting
always with the goes oh yeah she got
pregnant like 50 or 60 right yeah she's
gorgeous she's gorgeous
oh yeah you're right Flavor Flav's wife
yeah then they got a divorce and then
she remarried and that's what she got
pregnant crazy
Brigitte Nielsen's huh yeah boy she
reminds me of the [ __ ] Briana Tarsus
yeah the [ __ ] game of Thrones warrior
yup she's shortstop it's like five three
or something
damn dude she looks like I don't know do
i think that seven foot right there
think she's a good question six six
eleven brother
she's taller than the dude right Kenny
two inches is six feet she's taller than
the dude go back to the guy now they do
six feet I really wanna go back to her I
really like her fade it's cool huh yes
nice you know I wanted to ask this very
good would you would you rather [ __ ]
Flavor Flav oh ethic I don't or Michael
Blackson Michael Blackson
whoa what's up twinsies so flavor flavor
there's more Michael Blackson type in
Michael Blackson right now
Oh God Flavor Flav if he's next to
[ __ ] Flavor Flav I can imagine the
Flair cuz he makes me laugh boyfriend
Michael blow for funny guys hear me
you're a Flavor Flav no I'm Michael
Blackson Michael black isn't like a bus
you're the more default guy while there
now I think I would go from Michael
Blackson
can you show Michael Blackson
looks like Flavor Flav just if he was
just stated Africa now you gotta get
like a flava flav pay like a real one
look
like Smeagol in hip-hop clothes wait
Michael black I don't want a full plane
yes so this is Flavor Flav okay
god damn bees greasy this is Michael
blacks oh yeah there's nothing wrong
with a flavor flavor
he looks relate it to Eddie Murphy
younger he's cleaner he looks like his
smell agrees just look at ya he's not a
good disgusting looking dude dude is
greasy lately it looks like you should
be vacuumed
[Laughter]
brainerd Brigitte's when they were
together in case you guys wanted to see
her face dude I didn't even know he was
there oh yeah where he's in the corner
Oh fellas sure she's toast [ __ ] ah yeah
she's like six or something yeah she
would even towered over sliced along but
he's short too because she that's his
ex-wife they did I think one of the
Rocky movies together and he married her
Rocky was here before he's been to the
White House just drag his wife well
that's right jog away yeah
Oh Robbie would be shorter than her yeah
but they did them together you in
choosing yeah oh she does look familiar
yeah well she was also a warrior with
Conan Conan yeah yeah yeah yeah I
believe it oh that was her she's in a
bunch of [ __ ] dude man struggles wife
was [ __ ] [ __ ] hot - see that's her
that's what I things I do in real life
she was married to Ralph done during no
no she's granted sliced off oh yeah she
was married I'm [ __ ] historic path
yeah historian of nonsense yeah
useless [ __ ] garbage yes like don't
you let's [ __ ] know the struggles why
from everybody who said no words
throughout the whole yeah he says to a
room of people who don't care yes anyway
yeah this is this is the story look
alike with Dante I I would be I would be
terrified of that situation
yeah I mean I mean look at her yeah no
it's it's not the best situation if she
told you I'm ready to spend the rest of
my life with you you would run so as
he's running she's chasing after him
fully nude screaming telling him to come
back
yeah yeah and so they both got arrested
you get arrested
he said they both got arrested yes he
did I thought you said why didn't he get
arrested because he was he's black and
he's running ahead of her I guess
because he was found in possession of an
open house but I love gray goose chase
laboured vodka Raleigh metal grinder
containing marijuana wait so he's got a
bloody orange pills on top with assorted
pillow pockets pockets damn yeah cargo
pants so as he's running away he has to
make sure that he gets faded later on do
greatness is [ __ ] expensive dude that
shit's like 50 bucks cherry-flavored
oh no usually when you're scared you
just jet out or maybe he's already
buzzed he wants to keep his buzz so he's
running the bottle you think about ways
to the bus yeah this is like a 20
[ __ ] $5 bottle yeah so they're saying
that they both had a strong intoxicating
odor on their breath when officer spoke
to them they were both her breath looks
like smells like Vegas
Vegas machines it smells like the [ __ ]
it start us what's that [ __ ] what the
golden northern night their chips was
full of like [ __ ] finger crossed mold
yeah we had to go cuz it's too funny not
to go I know
oh and then you see that swimming pool
with people just doing in it doing is a
term yes just doing is the only
appropriate time I just like but don't
open your mouth in that water people
what are you doing little kids like it's
like no no no no no something in their
mouth like yeah you have happen now you
have absolutely have it okay that's good
I love the Golden Nugget it was great it
was great dude what a circus circus is
like a tradition I have to go to Circus
Circus every time there what are we
going back go back I know I gotta go
back I'd be going in March when in March
no it's all of us oh really mm-hmm
oh when I don't know I'll give you the
dates later Oh cuz I think I'm gonna
play this like March first or some [ __ ]
oh wait playlist is coming in April no I
think it's March we went in April last
year oh I think they moved its Martin
sometime in spring I don't know I don't
think I'm gonna go to playlist this year
I guess last year with the person last
year I'm gonna ever go to playlist full
we get it yeah unless they invite me
they need me on a panel the only reason
why I would go is because that was fun
with us yes that was really that was
Furman I wouldn't even go inside
playlist I'll just go to Orlando do you
mean we should just travel school I
don't know yeah pretty much it was a
waste of time going into playlist I
don't know but it was kind of sad about
going people watching it's funny though
yeah that's my favorite I have to do